Boy howdy
Hi, this is a tough
Ye-yes here. Are you practicing a little salute? Huh? Yes, you are. We'll take care of that won't we?
This is so much harder than I thought. Oh
That makes two of us
All right
Oh
God
That's why you're such a little bastard. No one's ever changed you
Yeah, you got a big stinky in there. Don't you gotta sounds like Hitler's anus which
Which would make sense wouldn't it? Yeah, I think we both know I don't have what it takes to do this
So I'm just gonna change her diaper real quick. And then I'm gonna come back with my friend cable. He loves killing you
Hey everybody, it's Charlie. So we got to talk about new Deadpool
We found out that Tim Miller was going to use the Fantastic Four in his version
So I'll explain what that deleted scene was if you're new to the channel
There's a new round of that blu-ray giveaway
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a comment on the video
Uh name a new winner at the end of this
The Hitler scene is just a play on the most asked question about time travel when talking about morality
Would you go back and kill Hitler if you had a time machine, so it's a moral question
But it's also a broader question
About the butterfly effect would killing Hitler in the past lead to something even worse because of something that we can't conceive of
because of the butterfly effect
They've already answered that question several times over on the flash when you try to alter the timeline to avoid some crazy future outcome
Time we'll find a way to replace that event with something even worse. I want you not to mess with the timeline
Dr. Wells if you would just let me tell you what was gonna happen. You'd understand why I did this whatever tragedy
You think you've just averted time will find a way to replace it and trust me Barry the next one
Could be much worse
They cut the scene during test screenings because they felt like it was too big of a bummer to send the movie
I don't like Deadpool killing a baby even though it was baby Hitler people were like
This is just too much of a bummer to go out on like they wanted to end it on that Green Lantern kill
You're welcome, Canada, just because that was kind of funny like making fun of Green Lantern is pretty safe for a Deadpool movie
God, damn, that's beautiful
You're welcome
I
didn't know about the second tag at the
very end of the credits though where he realizes that he can't do it the joke there being that he's gonna go get cable to
Do it because cable loves killing people the whole plot of the movie is about cable
going back into the past to alter the timeline by
Prematurely killing Julian Denison's fire fist character so that he can't do something terrible in the future
Which is exactly what Deadpool was trying to do in this Hitler scene
But you all want to know about the deleted Fantastic Four scene. So this is actually pretty crazy
We just found out that in the Tim Miller version of Deadpool 2 before he left the project
There were a couple different characters that he wanted to use and the plot of the movie was a little bit different
It felt a little bit different the character designs were a little bit different
So I'll talk about the biggest changes
But the whole thing with the Fantastic Four is that he was gonna have Colossus go to Yancy Street fight Ben Grimm
So it sounds like he was mostly hyping up Colossus versus the thing
But there were character designs for the entire cast of Josh Trank's Fantastic Four. You have the miles teller. Mr
Fantastic, you have Michael B Jordans Human Torch
So I think there are a couple reasons
Why that didn't end up happening like you can see why Fox might not want to remind people about that Fantastic Four movie
It's really expensive to do all those characters because they would have had to do all this CG
He wanted to do a very comic-book
Accurate version of the thing the way we found out about this was through the concept artist that was working with Tim Miller to develop
These scenes and he said the Tim Miller was very picky about the character models
I think a little bit of it also had to do with the Fantastic Four actor's signing off on that
Like could you imagine them going to Michael B Jordan?
Asking them to include his character in this movie right after Black Panther come out. I'm standing in your house
Serving justice to a man who stole your vibranium and murdered your people
Just as your teen couldn't deliver
One of the best Marvel characters and Marvel villains overall in the entire Marvel Cinematic Universe
Of any big superhero film kill monger was amazing
So it's crazy to think about his Fantastic Four performance after you watch Black Panther even the actor himself
when he was on stage at Comic Con a couple years ago when they announced the Black Panther movie and brought them on stage like
Hey, we're getting ready to shoot this. It's gonna be really cool
One of his comments was it's great to finally be in the good Marvel Universe
Which was like the biggest backhand to Fox's Marvel movies at the time
But now that the Disney deals going through it's all coming back around
Hopefully they'll have some fun with the idea that both Chris Evans and Michael B
Jordan have now played two different Marvel characters in really really big movies
Even though obviously Fantastic Four totally bombed that feels like something you would do in a Deadpool movie like legit MCU
Fantastic Four will probably be more serious even though Marvel films in general tend to have a lot of humor
They don't get quite as meta as Deadpool does with those in jokes, like making fun of all the continuity problems
Usually it just winds up being more spider-man making pop-culture references. It's all about to tense off to save the universe look dance-off
It's not it's not it's not I can still move exactly like photos
Is it still the greatest movie in history? It never was don't encourage this
Alright, we're getting no help from Flash Gordon here Flash Gordon, by the way
That's a compliment no more pop-culture references from you on this trip
I think it would have been an opportunity
To make them feel like they were actually pretty cool like you put them in a Deadpool movie
You have a really badass fight with the things so you turn him into a cool character
But you also Lampoon him with a whole bunch of jokes and talk about how ridiculous he is as a character
So it's like the same thing the Deadpool does with Colossus on a regular basis like they turn Colossus into a pretty cool character
but at every opportunity
Deadpool makes fun of him and points out how ridiculous he is. We can't allow this Deadpool
Please come close. Yeah big chrome
it's not nice for
Me trust me
That wheezing bag of dick tips. Has it coming the entire movie is Deadpool making fun of all the other characters
so you would have had to imagine that there would be a version of that with the
Fantastic Four in this the big thing about Yancy Street is that it's a big comic book location specific to the Ben Grimm character
It's down here on the Lower East Side. It's the location of the Yancy Street gang. It's like right around the Williamsburg Bridge here
They used to torment him when he was younger
Then they popped up later in the comics during the fear itself storyline
When Odin's brother cold?
Boursin took over Asgard and sent all the hammers down to earth to create the worthy one of the hammers fell to Yancy Street and
Transform Ben Grimm into angrier breaker of souls. So Yancy Street is just a really big Fantastic Four comic book location
So it would have been really cool
But you can see how doing like a whole extra scene with this. Big fight would have been crazy expensive
The movie was already really expensive and one of the things that makes the Deadpool character works
So well is that they do it so cheaply
Making fun of those big-budget superhero films like infinity war or any of the big DC films
Now that the Disney deal is going through I think the next time we do see Fantastic Four
It'll be legit. One of those characters will pop up in a Marvel movie
I've already done a couple of videos about what they plan to do with Deadpool and those characters
So I'll link that video at the end of this. I'm working on a new Avengers Illuminati video
so I'll post that next should be up in the next couple of hours, but
Congratulations to the giveaway winner from my last big video Arwa el Moussa. Please email me on the back end of my channel
So I can get your contact details
Click here for that new Avengers 4 titled teaser and click here tour and what Marvel's plans are for Deadpool in
Fantastic Four during phase 4 and phase 5. Thank you so much for watching. Everybody. Stay. Awesome. I'll see you guys tonight